now Bryan Cranston so many kind of
random things in your life you are an
ordained minister
I am indeed son yes there was a very
busy minister who encouraged you to pick
up the slack one of my summer jobs was
on Catalina Island off the coast of
California and befriended a guy named
Reverend Bob who was a great guy didn't
drink didn't do any drugs he just was
looking for a good time and he was a
Universal Life Church Reverend which was
actually started as a tax haven but they
also they did weddings he came to me one
day and said Brian I need you to perform
a wedding because I booked two weddings
same day same time different locations
and I what are you talking about I can't
do that he says no you can I'll just put
the certificate in the typewriter and
type in your name we send it off the
Secretary of State it gets you know
registered and you are legally a an
ordained minister and I said I can't do
this I really can this is the mid-70s I
can't do this but I really can't it pays
$200 I'll do so I said here's a copy of
Cahill Gibran people like that and just
you know it just talked to him then have
the bride sign here the groom sign here
you're done you know it's like okay so I
was I had hair down to here I was
sunburned I had shorts and flip-flops
and a Hawaiian shirt and I show up it
was at an airport and I'm looking around
and I thought oh my and this guy says
what who are you what I would I'm the
minister let's where are we gonna do
this he said we're gonna go into an
airplane a six seater airplane and we're
going once we get over the Hollywood
sign we want to start the ceremony I go
piece of cake no problem inside of
course I'm like we get inside I'm next
to the pilot then the bride and groom
and the witnesses in the back and that's
a twin-engine prop plane so I have to
scream so I'm in the back going
[Laughter]
don't stand at each other shatter
holding hands
I'm just wheeling and dealing but it was
it was an acting exercise and they were
holding hands and looking to me the the
figure of authority how many connections
are on this couch because Benedict you
can marry people
is this right we're gonna have a wedding
off yes marry people
yeah I made an amide row Brenda to his
partner Seth this judgement you know
judge window he married him I mean not
he didn't marry visa I mean there's so
many bits of it that are unlikely it's
you who it's gender it's a beaver well
he was way back when he was robbed
render that's that's who I was marrying
and we would be worried and yeah I
he's a judge now so yeah he I'm pretty
sure I could do that but I didn't ever
see any documentation but I'm I'm sure
it'll be honest I think they've done
that the serious stuff probably with
Brian in an aeroplane book yeah the real
serious just a sort of little bit of
icing on the cake and I be thirty was it
was amazing to do I didn't have to fight
the noise but it was the baking heat of
I be thoroughly okay to be honest it's
still whatever the situation to be near
people making that it's fantastic it's
an incredible thing to witness
and once we it was odd to now witness
what's happened to him but he's now
judge comes out he's there I mean it's
it's just extraordinary I think I had
the same yep there is no did you know he
could dance not like that
it's extraordinary and you needs a dear
friend and to watch anyone you know do
something unexpectedly brilliant like
that is yeah you just fill with pride
and it's it's very funny and very pretty
[Music]